i'm here with vince vaughn you might
have heard of them if you could give men
advice when it comes to picking up women
what advice would you give to men
we are here at model volleyball in south
beach the hottest event on the planet
and we're finding out what women are
looking for in a man let's talk dating
[Music]
here with sonia we're finding out what
beautiful women are looking for in a man
what are the top three qualities you're
looking for in a man being reliable that
they trust me and good in bed don't
slack buddy funny hot and a good
personality loyalty
ambition and caring intelligence i also
value a man who knows how to work with
like
saving and money just so we were clear
i've saved a lot of money
find someone who has the same values as
you also finding somebody that is
willing to
support you and everything that you do
and third thing someone that you can
have fun with dark hair fun outgoing and
uh latin white blonde guys need not
apply nothing confidence
loyalty and i mean this is a little
shallow but i mean they're going to look
good too brains humor
and a strong work ethic you have to be
dependable reliable and you have to be
nice that's all that's for is that too
hard to freaking ask gentlemen so if a
man did have all three of those
qualities on average
how how long would it take for him to
sleep with you what's up
with this
sleep with me oh my god oh it's gonna
take a pretty long time to get in bed
with all of this i don't sleep with
anyone until i'm in committed
relationship that's like my thing oh
well i'm a
catholic christian so until i was
married less than one
boom first day we're banging it depends
on the man
on average how often ten
ten dates
wow you gotta work hard for sonia
wow
these christians out there they don't
play that they're really committed okay
a few dates a few days yeah three days
yeah okay
maybe two
it depends if how good looking he's
maybe one if he's super good luck
and on the seventh day
god rested you can try three months
worth of dates i don't think it's like
there's a certain number like if i'm
feeling it then i'm feeling it if i'm
not then i'm not you know kind of
depends i mean maybe it won't even last
more than two dates but i like to get to
know a person and like to kind of build
a friendship before i actually run into
a relationship like maybe a month okay
well worth is that till silver
my thing is if i'm feeling the vibe and
the energy and i know that we're a match
i feel like let's see give us your best
advice when it comes to dating from sway
lee best advice make sure you come to
understanding kind of understanding
you know who you they know you dealing
with you know what i'm saying
and if she got instagram it ain't gonna
work and if he got instagram and they
gonna work try to pick someone that you
kind of like and have fun with always
better if you enjoy the person and enjoy
being around them sometimes you could be
in a hurry to pick someone up but then
you kind of don't know if you even get
along so it's always nice if you have
things in common and enjoy each other
we're here asking
women what they're looking for in a man
you're a pretty attractive high value
man what are you looking for in a woman
someone that saves that money
save that money let's talk pick up lines
if a guy wanted to get your number
what's the best approach
like if we're here hey girl i'll hold
this for you while you put my number in
no cheesy pickup lines do not come off
as a creep because like i can feel like
weird energy so like you know act like a
normal person i don't know i like cheesy
pickup lines i think they're funny
unless you're like weird then they're
not funny then you're just even more
creepy you have to be very respectful
walk up and be like i think you're so
beautiful yada yada i would like to get
to know you have a good conversation
before and then just ask for it you know
just be up front not like any kind of
cheesy pickup line i'll be like oh sorry
i lost my phone do you mind calling me
so i could find it
just like say hey how you're doing hey
how you doing victoria i'm like joey
from friends maybe casual conversation
hit it off first and then hit it with
the the phone number like can i get your
phone number yeah but like talk first
don't just come up to me and be like hey
you're pretty can i have your number
that does not work no
ever ever i guess just coming up to me
and like acting normal not so more of
like oh i can get you whatever you want
you know like kind of big hot shot stuck
up just someone like normal humble
genuine i usually give them my instagram
so that i can like see who they are like
make see i don't know who they're about
hi um what brings you here what's your
name like what do you do like you can
start that way general background yeah
background questions no just like just
come up and talk to me not be like
cringy you know some of those lines are
a little cringy and you're like
oh have you seen my friends
what does that mean i don't know i use
it all the time
have you seen my friends yeah and that's
how you like start talking to somebody
even
even when i'm not looking for my friends
amazing what's the worst approach worst
pickup line a guy could use oh my god
the
the whistle the
eh
i don't know why guys do that do you
believe in first in love at first sight
or you want me to come around again
that ain't gonna work for sonia hey are
you single
horrible it'd be like let's hang out you
know i hate that let's just hang out
like what do you mean hang out you know
you want to take netflix and chill don't
work for you it doesn't can i take a
quick survey like put your number it was
like some weird cheesy [ __ ] if anybody
approaches me and says something that is
physical about me
i don't like it hi you're pretty
that does not work no happened to me the
other day i ran away how you doing ma
like something like that the old mom
thing
ma
like ma
sweetie
it's just rude
hey baby girl how you doing you got a
man damn i just got really turned on
somehow the worst one i ever had is i
was actually at a baseball game with
four other
baseball wives and a guy a fan came up
to us and said so which one of you wants
to go on a date with me tonight and i
was like first of all rude second of all
if you want to go on a date with anybody
maybe next time don't approach all of
them like pick one okay how often
does a woman
say she has a boyfriend but she's lying
about
95 of the time because guys do not take
no lightly i mean i'm always honest i
don't know about everybody else but we
kind of live in miami so honestly i
think it's 50 50. a lot of times girls
say that just so you shut the [ __ ] up 50
50 you know
you never know right depends on who's
asking right yeah i mean that's a good
way to get out of a conversation i have
a boyfriend you know true so do you have
a boyfriend i do [ __ ]
80 of the time they're being truthful
really
75
probably 60 of the time 65 percent
she threw a 65 not at 60. not 70 65. i
don't think it matters necessarily if a
girl sings she has a boyfriend she's
obviously not interested in you so you
should not harass her it's that simple
well who knows it depends because if she
doesn't like the guy she would
definitely use that as an excuse to get
rid of so how often is she lying
all the time
other lion all the time probably 40 of
the time
i've said that and i'm completely single
but you're lying to a man do you feel
bad about lying
no because
if i'm uncomfortable and they keep
approaching me i'm gonna just be like yo
i'm just gonna call my boyfriend
normally i'll just be like hey i'm not
interested
what was that little dance movie
i don't know
final thoughts on dating relationships
money go for it you got nothing to lose
by the way i can't find my phone i think
i lost it would you mind calling me real
quick i totally would but i'll have my
photo
add value to people's lives i feel like
that makes you desirable what do you
think what have you learned from your
interview process that's a thank you
vince vaughn for asking me a question
i think
um that yes
for a guy i think it comes down to head
heart dick
okay you gotta have all three i got you
if a girl only is getting one of the
three it's never gonna work if you find
a girl that can stimulate the brain
is in your heart but then obviously the
sex is good
what the hell else is there what about
the ladies what did what did they what
you're gonna appreciate this yes
the number one quality that a woman has
said that she's looking for what do you
think it is funny
exactly
yeah people like to laugh and enjoy
their time
[Music]